hey Facebook live what's happening Chuck
nice here doing a little star talk all
stars with two of our all-stars our main
All Star which is Carolyn Porco dr.
Carolyn Porco and sitting next to me is
Shawn Lynn Sisseton hasta new assistant
all-star who if if you are interested
and I know that you are this Thursday
September 15th at the Beacon Theater you
guys will be doing star talk live douzo
at 7:00 doors open at 7:00 which is very
cool and and Startalk live of course is
when we have a live brought a live show
where we do what we normally do on
Startalk which is talk science right
yeah actually I've never been to one
I've never seen one so I'm I mean like
how wild does it get that's great yeah
all I can tell you is mmm pants are
optional so just keep that in mind I
wasn't expecting that I refused to wear
pants which is why we have this desk
here hey so we're we're Facebook live
right now which means that hopefully we
have some people out there who are
watching us and they're going to give us
some some queries just like me I'm
bracing myself and I actually have the
first one in my hand it's from alan tear
hey Alan what's happening buddy and he
says this shawn has music been an
important focus for the psychological
research in oh well it's not just so on
but has music been an important focus
for the psychological research in NASA
for their astronaut program for instance
do they try to encourage certain genres
to promote positive feelings or leave it
up to the personal taste it's all
gangster rap it's only game that it puts
you in a good mood wouldn't it like
waking up on Mars and hearing gangster
rap you know about that is there a
musical psychological component to
preparing to go to other planets I
unfortunately don't know those kinds of
details about how they are preparing
humans for long-duration flights but I
do know as you remember on the shuttle
they woke up the astronauts every
morning with some
song and on the on the is International
Space Station that guy did Ziggy
Stardust was it that's that's what I
mean they says they wake them up yeah
yeah no no he saw he did I mean is there
life on Mars was that other one he did
or did he know he did
ground control version of it in fact so
great that David Bowie said it was the
most poignant version he'd ever heard it
was being kind no I'm joking no it was
alright let's take another question for
hard
aash I'm asking for hot but you know
your last name
alright why is our solar system so flat
and everything is on one orbital plane
oh and there's no please the good
question yes please Carolyn tell me the
same thing about Saturn's rings it's the
same deal it has to do with I'm sorry
I'm gonna get nerdy on you but it has to
do with the loss of energy and the
conservation of angular momentum nice
okay how much of a micro solar system is
Saturn in terms of the way planets and
you know planetoids form well put aside
the rings which we think are kind of an
aborted well we think there are moons
that had gotten smashed up and they're
so close to Saturn where the gravity
gradient is so great they can't coalesce
again so they're in equilibrium they're
not going to turn into planets
eventually our little moons eventually
go they will probably disappear but
they're not going to turn into little
moons but the rest of the moons are all
well the ones within about ten million
kilometers they're all rotating or
revolving around Saturn in the same
direction and they came from a cloud of
material in the same way that the solar
system formed from a cloud of dust and
gas and so on it had some innate
original rotation and so it had a
preferred vector in space a rotational
axis in space and in that circumstance
when you have material that collides and
loses energy but it retains the angular
momentum along that axis it ends up what
happens is it all collapses down into a
plane it is unwise relaxed rotating in
the other direction
why is it clockwise well it could have
gone solar system which is cavalry got
hit by an impact right Uranus is also on
its side if you have remember this
happens at a time when it's late in the
solar systems early the late part of the
early formation right system it's the
end of the beginning and you still have
large impactors coming and hitting
things and they can alter the angle
momentum but because of this loss of
energy and conservation of angular
momentum
there are basically two shapes in the
universe there are spheres and they're
discs and one can evolve into the other
nice I anticipability is only have a few
geometries that they can take right
there's like a well they're a little bit
more messy because you're galaxies and
then what else
spiral galaxies are all disk galaxies so
they they they take this form it flat no
but you know other galaxies are can they
can be the result of the merger of
galaxies colliding which we're on our
way to meet and you have a date with
Andromeda Jerry but it's fun to think
about like Andromeda being so much
bigger in the sky right do you know if
we had eyes that were far more sensitive
than we do and we could actually you
know store up the the energy that that
likes yeah like a cat I don't know if a
cat can do that but I do know that
Andromeda galaxies would be twelve moons
across oh that's how big it would be
what is that thing they could a great
attractor I was besides your man breasts
that was the inappropriate there isn't
there an unknown attraction towards a
certain area of the universe that
doesn't have to do with the direction
that we should normally be moving
actually I don't know anything about
this stop they call it the Great
Attractor and all the galaxies in our
neighborhood are moving in that
direction but you should maybe it's just
part of the local the group that
was asking you thank you
it's the great could just be James Brown
the Great Attractor
alright hey Krystal kind to wants to
know this I would like to know more
about
osiris-rex I know asteroids are an issue
but what is the likelihood of any
potential disaster would be officially
disclosed I don't know exactly what
crystal means there but Osiris about
osiris-rex I thought it's a mission
that's gonna go and pick up a sample
from an asteroid and come back with it
so it's gonna be a sample return mission
return listen maybe she's referring to a
disaster where the thing is making its
way through the atmosphere and the
container cracks open I don't know
there's no people involved it's not
gonna be supposed to send back the
container and then the containers gonna
land somewhere in a desert of Utah right
I mean we kind of have done this already
with a mission called Stardust which
returned material from a comet it did
crash the container we shouldn't be
worried because we're constantly being
rained with debris from space anyway I
mean oh is that what they owe oh is that
worth that's all like like the Andromeda
Strain no I think they probably have all
that planetary protection what she means
yeah like we're bringing back substances
from outer space do you know is there a
possibility that we could be bringing
back I'll tell you that planetary
protection is a huge issue for those of
us who want to explore places like
Enceladus
because we do think that very likely
there could be some if not adamant if
not mmm no if not full organisms but
material for that is biological and we
want eventually to bring back a sample
and we have to worry about how to
protect the earth from contamination
it's a big issue it's like as in money
too it would cost a lot of money to put
all the safeguards in place so it's
being it's being examined okay cool
let's Space Station as an intermediate
you know lab to look at what you got
first you've you've read on this
you've read about this yeah a little bit
oh my god he's up on everything yet
they're thinking about putting all the
like operating devices that would study
it in orbit and just doing it all in
orbit but that and even bringing back
much larger samples to like being able
to grapple like a big giant something
and bring it back and leave it at then
yeah you know just we could be
considering that yeah they're
considering things like that from Mars
all right this is a Marin house
you always pick the people with the
really difficult names but for Americans
they're not difficult for them my man
exactly it's difficult for me you know
what I don't care what your name is it
difficult for me for some reason
okay I'm terrible with names this is
what he says III detect a little like a
little bit of an irksome quality in his
question why does NASA focus on dead
rocks like Mars for life discovery
oh you've asked oh he's asked the wrong
person oh really well because this is
like one of those things that gets I
have a bee in my bonnet about this I
know I think he's that's the right first
see right yeah and let's hear what you
know you know there was a time long ago
when Mars was the place to go it made so
much sense to go and look there but
we've been there with mission after
mission after mission all the Mars
people are gonna hate me after this now
Enceladus is where it's that the outer
solar system is really where it's at
because you know the even the mantra and
NASA is follow the water follow what
hate and screener because later
propensity for life to exist in watch
greater change we're open and Enceladus
folk what would you bet hey you know the
answer to this I do I just want you yeah
of course it's Enceladus nice not be
caught that's him not because not
because Enceladus has a greater chance
of having life it's because it's Ocean
expressed as these phenomenal geysers
shooting into space is so much more
accessible so we could do all the things
we've all talked about doing like what
kind of instruments what are the bio
signatures we go after you know how do
we you know back up one approach by
having another we could do all that on
Enceladus now very cool
very cool Asian actually we have an
answer to the the Great Attractor I
don't have time to read it but that's
great they are answering the James Brown
brown and Elvis getting in a hot tub
okay I would see that no that's great
and actually a lot of people were
talking about what is what are they
saying oh man he's giving a crap I lost
it now he gave me it
okay let me just say the Great Attractor
is a gravitational anomaly in the
intergalactic space within the vicinity
of the Hydra Centaurus super cluster and
it's a lot more and more and more with
that
oh is it dark matter is it a dark matter
yes so dazzling Maslin man thank you
brother that was a great great little
answer that you I hope to sell yes thank
you
let's see an anomaly just means we don't
know what it is well but if it's a
greater if it's a gravitational anomaly
means things are being the thing the
stuff around it is behaving as if
there's a lot of mass there's all the
galaxies in our neighborhood it must be
a big thing it could be a lot of dark
matter it's maybe we're like I mean
that's really all matter the truth is
all we really observe is anomalies right
for the most part when when when when
something acts as if it's being acted
upon that's the indication that
something's going on the planet 9 is
there right exactly we haven't never
seen Planet X or planet 9 we haven't
seen it
we haven't found it you haven't found it
but we know something's happening and so
we haven't a tional wobbles right okay
so cool band name all right here we go
I like obliquity obliquity liquid
liquidy it's kind of gonna turn off a
certain fan base but we'll get there
will our fans it sounds like my jazz
project someone says hey Sean stop
showing off Sean is definitely one of
the most science literate guests we have
ever I know what raising amazing can I
could do I get brownie points for this
do I get question points because Carolyn
bought us I brought him I brought him
here sauce I am
turned out to be a good talent scout and
by the way you're gonna get to see these
guys this Thursday at the Beacon Theater
doors open at 7:00 and it is Startalk
live it is September 15th Thursday and
you can still get tickets and you'll get
more of this banter and you'll also have
Neil deGrasse Tyson who I like to call
the other black guy funny I call I refer
to Neil and I is the tokens well yeah
because he and I kind of came up the
ranks we ended up off into on panels
together you know before he got really
famous and it was clear that he was the
token black guy and well you know things
have changed change have you seen the
pictures of him in his wrestling outfit
yes he was young he was looks like he
was fishing for the mods bribe he did
look a little like link from the Mod
Squad hey guess what Facebook life
thanks for joining us I think we're
gonna do some mortis kind of stuff you
know it seems as though from the
reaction that I'm getting here on
Facebook that people really dig it so
thanks a lot for all the support guys we
really appreciate it
all right ciao ciao